Et on se rend sur le terrain
à Kaboul rencontrer Victoria
Fontan. Vous êtes vice-
présidente de l'Université
américaine d'Afghanistan
à Kaboul. Vous êtes
une ressortissante française.
Et vous attendez, et vous
espérez un jour quitter.
Racontez-moi où vous en êtes
dans ces démarches.
VICTORIA FONTAN, ressortissante
française, vice-présidente, AUAF
- Alors, je suis... Bonsoir.
Je suis dans un "compound"
près de l'aéroport de Kaboul,
à 10 kilomètres, et donc,
j'attends de pouvoir rallier
l'aéroport pour prendre un vol.
Alors, différents vols ont été
affrétés. Il y a bien sûr
les vols de rapatriement
organisés par le Quai d'Orsay
et l'ambassade de France.
Et puis, il y en a d'autres
de par d'autres biais. Le souci,
bien sûr, c'est de pouvoir
rallier l'aéroport, sachant
que maintenant, de toute façon,
l'aéroport est fermé, le côté
militaire ainsi que le côté
civil. Donc, de toute façon,
tant que... comment dire,
les deux tarmacs sont investis
par la population afghane qui
elle-même veut pouvoir prendre
ces avions, nous ne pourrons
pas... Aucun avion ne pourra
atterrir et donc nous ne
pourrons pas nous-mêmes partir.
- On a vu ces images
saisissantes de l'aéroport
aujourd'hui encore. Hier,
cet hélicoptère qui a quitté
l'ambassade américaine,
ce désarroi, cette accélération
de l'histoire. Est-ce que vous,
ça vous a surprise, la vitesse
avec laquelle les talibans
sont entrés à Kaboul?
- Totalement. Il y a
une semaine, notre "board"
nous demandait de rentrer
et on leur disait :
Ne vous inquiétez pas,
ça va mettre... si ça arrive,
ça mettra quelques semaines,
Kaboul ne tombera pas.
Et pourtant, nous sommes tous,
comment dire... En fait, moi,
je suis experte en étude de paix
et conflits, Donc, j'aime penser
que je réussis peut-être
à analyser la situation,
à analyser les choses.
Et là, mais aucun de nous
n'a vu le coup venir.
Et je crois que les talibans
l'on dit eux-mêmes lors
de l'une de leurs déclarations.
Pour eux, ça a été très,
très vite. Ils ne s'y
attendaient pas. Et donc voilà,
tout le monde a été pris
de court. La désintégration
de l'État afghan, comment dire,
jamais je n'aurais pu
la prédire aussi vite.
- Et comment on va faire, bon,
le Canada est dans le pétrin,
parce qu'on doit ramener
des gens qui ont travaillé
avec les Forces canadiennes,
mais là, il n'y a plus
d'ambassade canadienne,
il n'y a plus d'avions.
Bon, les Français, vous l'avez
dit, vont affréter des avions.
Comment vous voyez la suite
des choses pour tous ces Afghans
qui ont entre guillemets
travaillé, collaboré
avec les forces de l'Ouest?
- Écoutez, je pense que ce sera
quasiment impossible d'en sauver
même une partie infime. Il faut
bien dire que les talibans ont
des listes, qu'ils savent très
bien qui a travaillé pour qui.
Mes professeurs eux-mêmes ont
été, comment dire, à maintes
reprises menacés dans l'année
passée, à recevoir des SMS...
D'ailleurs, l'un d'entre eux
est venu se réfugier au Canada
il y a quelques mois. Il est
en demande d'asile en ce moment.
Donc, c'est vraiment
une situation d'extrême urgence,
une situation de vie ou de mort.
- Parlez-moi des prochains jours
à Kaboul. Comment vous voyez
la suite? Et là, je ne parle
même pas des prochains mois,
mais des prochains jours du mois
d'août pour tous ces gens,
ces femmes qui travaillent,
ces juges femmes afghanes,
comment vous voyez la suite
des choses? Est-ce que vous
y croyez, à ce discours,
un peu plus soft des talibans?
- Non, je pense que c'est
une façon pour eux d'essayer
de redorer leur blason afin
d'obtenir une reconnaissance
diplomatique internationale.
Rappelons-nous que, ne serait-ce
que la semaine dernière,
toutes les puissances étrangères
ont dit aux talibans
par voie de messages, par voie
de déclaration, leur ont dit :
"Si vous accédez au pouvoir
par la force, nous ne vous
reconnaîtrons pas." Il faut
savoir qu'hier, comment dire,
la narrative talibane était :
"Nous n'entrons pas dans Kaboul,
nous restons aux portes
de Kaboul pour justement
ne pas prendre la ville
par la force." Mais ça,
ce n'était pas vrai parce que,
moi, j'y étais. J'avais,
comment dire, j'avais
des rapports de personnes
qui sont venues dans
mon "compound" au fil
de la journée et qui ont vu
les talibans, comment dire,
dans Kaboul en pleine journée.
Donc, je peux vous dire
qu'il y a eu des combats juste
aux portes de mon université
entre les forces de sécurité
afghane, qui étaient
nos voisins, et les talibans.
Donc, ça, nos collègues l'ont
entendu. Kaboul a été prise
de force. Tel est le cas.
Donc, cette reconnaissance
internationale ne doit surtout
pas venir. Et je sais que
le Canada sera au rendez-vous
et ne tombera pas
dans le panneau peut-être...
comme nation.
- Qu'est-ce qui va arriver
dans les rues de Kaboul,
dans les maisons où des gens
travaillaient, qu'est-ce qui
va arriver, d'après vous,
à Kaboul?
- Alors, déjà ça a commencé,
des recherches de maison
en maison dans certains
quartiers pour voir qui
a travaillé pour les forces
occidentales, comment dire,
les ordinateurs sont confisqués,
les téléphones portables,
les gens sont terrorisés.
J'ai des membres de la faculté
qui sont en train de détruire
leur ordinateur, de détruire
tout ce qu'ils ont
de l'université si c'est ça
qui va se passer, et c'est
en train de commencer
malheureusement, donc il ne faut
surtout pas, surtout pas se dire
qu'on a affaire à des gens
différents des années 90.
Ils n'ont pas changé. Ils sont
revenus, ils sont là pour
en découdre avec tous les autres
qui ont travaillé pour
les puissances occidentales.
- Donc ce sera, dites-vous,
Madame Fontan, en terminant,
un régime aussi terrifiant
que celui qu'on a connu
il y a 20 ans?
- Absolument. Et le paradoxe
de ce qui se passe en ce moment
du fait que toute
cette population a investi
le tarmac, quelque part, c'est
pour faire en sorte que nous
ne partions pas parce que, pour
moi, c'est de l'intelligence
collective inconsciente,
mais si nous, on part,
dès qu'on sera partis,
l'épuration va vraiment
commencer, comment dire,
de façon absolument implacable.
Et tant que l'on reste,
nous, otages quelque part
de cette situation à Kaboul...
Voilà. Je pense que c'est
ce qui est en train
de se passer.
- Victoria Fontan,
vice-présidente de l'Université
américaine en Afghanistan.
Vous êtes à Kaboul, vous
attendez d'être rapatriée
en France. Merci
de nous avoir parlé.